so one of my favorite movie makers is
Miyazaki from the famous Studio Ghibli
movies he created Spirited Away My
Neighbor Totoro and house Moving Castle
a few years ago a documentary came out
that recorded his insanely dedicated
working style the Kingdom of Dreams and
madness he rises at 6am each morning and
exercises and then takes his coffee and
arrives at Studio Ghibli by 9 am sharp
working Saturdays and holidays too he
draws all of the film's initial
storyboard by himself by hand which is
something almost none of the other big
animators do several times after the
completion of one of his films Miyazaki
would suggest that the studio be shot
down and all his stuff be fired no one
was ever sure if he was just kidding he
is known for his endless amount of
determination and motivation to Everyday
get up and work on some of the most
beautiful films but how does he do it
and what is the source of his motivation
and that is the topic that I want to
dive into today and I want to teach you
about Neuroscience of motivation and
everything to optimize your motivation
for the certain goals that you want to
achieve so hi I'm shallots a second year
PhD student in computational
neuroscience and today we will discuss
the Neuroscience of motivation or the
will and this is a follow-up video of a
previous video that I made about the way
or how to achieve your goals so also
check that one out if you haven't seen
it but today we will really dive deep
into how to emote yourself and what is
the Neuroscience behind motivation and I
will give you at the end of this video
three tools that are steeped in
Neuroscience such that you may optimize
for motivation in your daily life so
let's get straight into it so in our
brain different parts of our brain
regulate reward prediction we have the
orbital frontal cortex the anterior
singlet and the basal lateral amygdala
and all of these have been shown to be
correlated with reward prediction error
but as I've said in Neuroscience
nowadays people believe that it's more a
network type of connection between the
different areas of our brain that
usually accounts for higher level types
of behavior but what it comes down to in
the end is a cost versus benefit type of
analysis that your brain makes when it
looks at a certain goal and based on
this cost versus benefits it decides if
it's motivated enough to do that so
let's dive into this cost versus benefit
analysis so we have our costs which are
usually effort time discomfort pain Etc
and we have the benefits which are
potential prices meeting our
psychological and physiological needs
and somewhere in between these two we
decide our motivation to strive forward
towards our goals and usually these
costs and benefits depend on three types
of things so we have our physiological
State our environment and our our past
history so if we break it down into
these three components we can kind of
play around with these three components
and optimize for these such that our
cost benefit analysis is positive
towards the benefits and we increase our
motivation so one of the goals this
semester for me is to get a little bit
better at French I used to be quite good
at French when I lived in France but I
haven't really been for the past two
years so I really want to increase my
level and probably be able to read a
full book in French so I will walk you
through the three topics that I talked
about to see how I optimize for them to
really allow for my goal to get better
in French to come real and hopefully as
I walk you through you will also get
some tips and some tools such that you
can also optimize for the goals that you
want to achieve so for motivation one of
the main components is our physiological
state so that's how rested we are in
which part of our circadian rhythm we
are how much stress we had have we eaten
and all these type of factors combined
to decide how we feel usually and what
state our body is in and you probably
know that if you haven't rested properly
it's just really hard to focus on a
certain type of task so if you look at
right now your physiological stage you
close your eyes and you just kind of
feel where you're at decide if you think
that your body is at a good place right
now and if your physiological State
isn't really at the place that you want
it the thing that people in Neuroscience
or that's grounded in the Neuroscience
of motivation and reinforcement learning
is to start Behavior change with modest
goals and rewards even the smallest
steps towards them new behaviors emerge
slowly because they usually work against
the power of Prior reinforcement so
that's to say that if we want to
introduce new healthy habits to increase
the well-being of our physiological
State we kind of have to introduce them
slowly and carefully so for example if
you want to be a little bit better
rested it's good to go to bed for
example 15 minutes earlier and not
immediately decide that today I'm gonna
sleep at nine o'clock and I'm gonna wake
up at five because the probability of
you doing that based on your prior
reinforcement learning is just very low
and another thing I want to talk about
is a little bit like deep rest the
concept of deep rest so you've probably
heard the concept of deep work but I
think something that we don't think
about enough is deep rest so we have
these kind of shallow rest moments
throughout our week for example really
good meal or taking having a talk with a
friend but I think it's also good to
plan throughout your week one day where
you really have really focus on
depressed and that is for example really
disconnecting from the internet from
your phone taking a long walk out in
nature or having a really deep good
conversation with a friend and I think
this is as opposed to these sporadic
moments that we have of relaxation which
is like watching a YouTube video or
having a drink for example and I think
these are usually more coping strategies
these are not really these deep rest
moments so when you look at your week
try to for example in the weekend pick
one day where you really try to
disconnect from everything and the
second topic that we can play with when
we look at motivation is our environment
so when we think of our environment It's
usually the availability of the goal
that decides if we pursue the goal so
for example if you walk past a
restaurant and you're a little bit
hungry the chances of you being
motivated to go to that restaurant and
order a delicious meal increase
significantly and that's why when you
think of your goals and your motivation
it's good to optimize your environment
such that it really allows you to
achieve your goals quite easily so for
example you can decide in your room to
just have one place where you only do
work so every time you want to relax you
leave that place and every time you want
to work you go towards that place and
that way at a certain point your brain
kind of starts identifying that place
with work and at a certain point you
will also start to notice that as soon
as you enter that place you kind of go
into this work mode mindset another
topic that you can play with when you
think of your environment is actually
time so the timing of day or the time
when you do something is part of our
temporal environment I would say so our
temporal environment can for example be
that you every morning you do an hour of
French in my case and that way when that
hour arrives you kind of signify to your
brain ah it's French time so right now I
plan my hour of French in the weekend
and the way I'm doing it is with this
language school linguda it's an online
Language School who was kindly enough to
also sponsor this video so I used to be
as I said quite good at French Bob
because I don't really have people to
practice with it's becoming really hard
for me and that's why I really like
linguda as you can see they have these
kind of chapters and you can see your
progress so I'm still not very far but
when I book a class right now I'm
learning about the difference and I'm
learning a little bit all about
immigration which I think is a really
interesting topic and I first personally
really believe that the fastest way to
learn a language is to speak with a
native speaker and in the case of
linguda all their teachers are native
speakers so I hope you joined this
language learning Challenge and perhaps
pick an hour in the weekend to really
optimize for your language learning and
if you're super motivated linguda also
has this amazing language prints so the
linguda language print is a two-month
intensive challenge that requires
students to register at least for 15 or
30 lessons a month and if students take
part in every lesson they can receive 50
to 100 cashback so that means that it
would be totally free if you're
extremely motivated so if you are trying
to learn a language I think this is a
really cool challenge to do and I highly
recommend signing up you can use the
link down in the description below or
just check linguda out for yourself so
the last thing you can optimize for is
your narrative or your history and this
is a little bit more difficult because
it is usually our experiences of the
goal or our responses to a stimuli and
we cannot really change those because
these are usually just inherent to us
but we can play around a little bit with
the goals that we pick so it has been
written that a behavior will hold
greater subjective value to the degree
that it relates to one's core values and
sense of self identity linked goals are
more likely to be successful than
identity irrelevant or identity counter
ones and this really just boils down to
really thinking about what are your core
values and do the goals that you've
picked actually match your core values
because I sometimes see that people are
really unmotivated to do certain work or
certain type of behavior and it usually
boils down to that they don't really
relate to that goal so for example for
me my core values are wisdom creativity
and health slash happiness so usually
when I pick my goals I do try to think
about do these goals actually align with
the type of values that I want to pursue
in my life so if you are still not sure
about your values there is this list of
values online and if you have some time
I think it's cool to kind of go over it
and pick three that really resonate with
you and then try to see if you can fit
your goals to your certain values and if
you notice that some of your goals don't
really fit your core values it is maybe
a good moment to reflect if these goals
fit you and fit the life that you want
to lead so these were my tips for
increasing motivation if you have any
tips for me I would love to hear them so
put them down in the comments below and
otherwise see you next week bye